jim's in the classic eggman character  look he has his head shaved his mustache  is bigger than his face papa's got a  brand new stash  and no one was happier than jim carrey  to get to do that look it really brought  so many ideas and really brought out his  performance  [Applause]  the moustache is a manifestation of  robotnik's eco the bigger the ego the  bigger the chip the bigger the  resentment the bigger the mustache it's  a status symbol it is absolutely his  power  it's not big enough as far as i'm  concerned not only is he gonna be manic  have these great looks but we've  designed a ton of new drones for him and  the other fantastic thing we're so  excited to be able to bring to the  screen is his eggmobile his flying ship  that's iconic from the game  in the first movie he had a much more  grounded spaceship called the eggpot now  he'll be in that solo flight cab in the  eggmobile and it looks just like the  game and is fantastically designed  later  haters take me with you